j'ai lu l'article que vous avez publié
il est d'une exceptionnelle valeur
scientifique
mon intuition me dit qu'il existe un
autre élément vous croyez avoir
découvert un nouvel élément
la science est en train de changer et
ceux qui la dirigent aujourd'hui sont
les mêmes que ceux qui étaient
convaincus que la terre était plate
veulent y ait quitté mon laboratoire
science ne suffit pas alors c'est que
vous l'avez très mal comprise je vais
prouver qu'ils ont tort sur tout ce que
les atomes était fini et stable ce n'est
pas le cas pour certains d'entre eux
j'ai appelé cela la radioactivité
notre découverte pourrait soigner le
cancer c'est extraordinaire tu vas
changer le monde
notre travail est en lice pour le nobel
la nomination le fait ac de mon nom tu
as volé mon génie comment aussi tu
attribues leur ratio serait plus
important que tout ce qui m'intéressait
c'était la science il y en a qui disent
que mon radium les rend malades
on peut se demander si l'humanité a
avantage à connaître les secrets de la
nature
j'ai passé ma vie entière à essayer de
comprendre la possible si mon combat et
je le remporterait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]